so we start off with the kenyan election
let's go live straight away to the
electoral commission
announcement in nairobi
and for those who will come
we have prepared for you
what the concession and
an independent
electoral commission
so i just want to thank the staff of ibc
the soldiers who braved
insults harassment
and delivered right from the
constituencies
to the counties and up to the national
telling center
i want to thank
stakeholders state and non-state
stakeholders who have worked with us on
this journey
and more particularly
the members of the
diplomatic community and the religious
leaders who have been
keeping vigil at this center
for the last three days
they have been here throughout
24 hours a day
[Applause]
so kenyans came out and voted on the 9th
of august
and these are the results
of what the
will of the kenyan people reflect these
results and in the public quarter the
same results which i am reading here are
the ones in the public portal
[Applause]
there are four presidential candidates
these are the aggregated results
odinga raila
total valid votes
six million nine hundred and forty two
thousand nine hundred and thirty
and this represents
48.85 percent
achieve the number of counties the
candidate attained
with at least 25 percent of the total
valid votes cast in 34 counties
[Applause]
williams somewhere
number of valid votes
7 million
[Music]
thank you 7
176
100
this represents
50.49 percent
and he achieved
the minimum number of 39 counties
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
0.44
and
a number of counties
with a minimum of 25 percent obtained
zero
so
in accordance with the law the
conclusion and the law
i will follow your country
chairperson of the independent
electorate and boundaries commission
[Applause]
hereby declares that
root william somewhere
[Applause]
of id number 6847208
has been duly elected as the president
[Applause]
of the republic of kenya under the
provisions of article 138
of the constitution in the presidential
election
[Music]
held on 9th of
day of august
2022
and i'll proceed to sign
the certificate
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i invite the
president-elect to come forward and
receive his certificate
[Music]
is
so there you have it uh the kenyan
election chief declaring william ruto
winner of the presidential race
uh just under seven million votes
for ryla odinga just over 7 million
votes
for william ruto very close run thing
william ruto
is president-elect but
but will it be accepted we've already
seen chaotic scenes
at the electoral commission at the telly
center there
where william ruto is receiving
congratulations
for his
for winning the election
the question is
what is going to happen next let's
listen again
to president elect thank you
i invite
[Applause]
i invite
the president-elect to make his remarks
and thank you
kenyans for having a peaceful election
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much
asante sana
um
your
excellencies
ambassadors
and high commissioners present
your lordships the bishops
and members of the clergy
in the republic of kenya
my good deputy
regaviga
distinguished
members of the
independent electoral and boundaries
commission led by
chairman
wafula bukati
fellow countrymen
and women
good evening
it is
a wonderful evening
and i want to thank god
that
we are here this evening
to witness
this momentous occasion
as
the people of kenya
restate
what is in article one of the
constitution of kenya
that all suffering power
belong to the people of kenya
i want to thank
god for
getting us to this point
i want to thank god
that today
we have concluded
this election
i know
that there were predictions
that i won't get
to the ballot
there were predictions
that we won't get here
but because there is a god in heaven
we are here
and i want to in a very special way
say
and confess
that without god
we wouldn't have been here
[Applause]
my gratitude also goes to the people of
kenya
the millions
who listen to us
the millions who participated in our
campaigns peacefully
the millions who turned up to vote
for us
on 9th of august
and
the millions who have waited patiently
until this announcement has been made
specifically i want to thank
my fellow countrymen and women
because we have raised the bar
in this election
jointly we have raised the bar this
election
was much
about the issues
than
the ethnic configurations that have
always
informed our elections
[Applause]
gratitude goes to the millions of
kenyans who refused
to be boxed into
tribal cocoons
i am a very proud kenyan this evening
that the people of kenya have raised
the bar on us
who are seeking leadership in our
country
not to sell our ethnicities but to sell
our programs
our manifestos
our agenda and our plan
let me also
say right
at the start
that in here
and in this election
there are
no losers
the people of kenya have won
because we have raised the political bar
i want to say
that
the people of kenya
led by the 14 million who stand up to
vote
are the biggest winners
the hero
of this election
is the iebc
led by wafula bukati
i say this
with conviction
that the iebc
amazed all of us
with the results in the public portal
the all the servers were open
and everybody all you needed
is a simple calculator
and you would have the results
i want to congratulate the iebc for
raising the bar
and i want to say without fear of any
contradiction
that one wafula bugatti
is our hero
soft-spoken
but farm
and i want to tell you mr chairman
we are very proud that without informing
anyone of us
you put all the results
from all the polling stations
on a public portal
where any kenyan could access
that became the game changer in this
election
let me also
at this point in time
thank our
partners the religious leaders
who
were part of this process right from the
beginning
for the first time we saw religious
leaders spend time
at this darling center
and prayed for this process
i am sure their prayers will not be in
vain
i also want to thank
[Applause]
our development partners
our diplomatic community
and all the observers
who came
in their thousands
to be part and
parcel
of the process
right from
almost two weeks ago
to its conclusion in this auditorium
to all of them
i tell them the people of kenya are
eternally grateful
that you took your time
valuable time
to watch over this process
so that the right thing
can happen
i want to thank my wealthy competitor
the honourable railroading
for
a campaign
that we all dwelt on issues
and we try to sell an agenda to the
people of kenya
i want to promise
that
i will work
with all elected leaders
and all leaders in kenya
so that we can fashion a country
that leaves nobody behind
what the people of kenya have done
they have assigned us responsibilities
there will be those of us who will be in
the executive
but there will be those of us
who will oversee
what we do in the executive
both responsibilities in government and
in the opposition
are important for the people of kenya
[Applause]
i want to promise the people of kenya
that
i will run a transparent open
democratic government
and i will work with the opposition to
the extent
that they provide oversight
over my administration
[Applause]
let me also
at this point in time
acknowledge
my boss
the president of the republic of kenya
his excellency uhuru
kenyatta who has worked with me
over the last 10 years
in various forms
and
i want to commit to the people of kenya
but i will build on the foundation
that president kenyatta and i
put together
and take this country to the next level
i want to promise
all the people of kenya whichever way
they voted
that this will be their government
i know many
are wondering
especially
those who have
done many things against us
i want to tell them
that they have nothing to fear
there is no room
there is nothing there is no room for
vengeance there is no room
for looking back
we are looking into the future
i am acutely aware
that our country
is at a stage
where we need all hands on deck to move
it forward
we do not have the luxury
to look back
we do not have the luxury
to point fingers
we do not have the luxury to apportion
blame
we must
close
ranks and work together
for
a functioning
democratic
prosperous kenya
i want to thank
the members of my team
starting
with my wife and family
and many other
prayer warriors
in kenya
and i want to confess
that
i have been prayed into victory
it is not
our effort
and my team knows
we were working against the odds
many odds are that
but
i must confess
that it is god
who brought us
this victory